direct avec jean paul stahl
infectiologues aussi à chu de grenoble
alpes à bonsoir jean paul stahl merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france comment
est-ce que vous analysez ces chiffres
alors il ya ces augmentations de cas
déclarés 1314 1300 près près de mille
cinq cents ou près de 1400 pardon et en
même temps très peu de morts 26
enregistrés ces dernières 24 heures
comment est ce que vous expliquez cela
on va tout simplement d'abord parce que
l'on n'a pas encore le nombre de
personnes hospitalisées en réanimation
on avait il ya quelques mois donc
forcément en le nombre absolu étant plus
faible même si le pourcentage reste
quand même le nombre de décès est plus
faible
ça c'est le premier point puis le
deuxième point c'est que l'on sait mieux
traiter les malades on est les traite
plus précocément en particulier avec des
corticoïdes puisqu'on a bien montré que
maintenant que c'était efficace donc la
prise en charge des patients est
meilleure ce qui explique sans doute le
moins de décès mais enfin il faut pas il
faut pas se contenter de ça il faut bien
constater que l'épidémie est en
augmentation et donc il faut tout faire
pour essayer pas ralentir
c'est ça que les français ont du mal à
comprendre on dit que le go que
l'épidémie est en augmentation puisque
les cas maintenant sont dépistés en
masse et forcément le nombre évidemment
est élevé mais comment est-ce qu'on peut
dire que c'est plus élevé qu'en mars
alors qu'il n'y avait pas de dépistage
là on a du mal à comprendre c'est que
l'augmentation des cas et supérieurs à
l'augmentation des tests tout simplement
il ya un vrai décalage alors les tests
sont bien entendu responsables pour une
part de cette augmentation des cas mais
pour une part seulement et est donc le
reste c'est lié à une bague accélération
de la contagion
alors on a aussi du mal à comprendre la
politique du gouvernement les français
sont un peu perdus on voit que les
journées du patrimoine sont maintenus
les métros
ont enlevé l'or leurs mesures de
distanciation et les métros sont bondées
à paris et dans le même temps certaines
villes resserre les boulons si je puis
dire ferme des restaurants plutôt
limitée rassemblement comment comment
est-ce que vous analysez vous en tant qu
infectiologues ces mesures très
simplement que l'ensemble du territoire
et pas et pas à la même enseigne pas
logés à la même enseigne
le lia certaines villes où la
circulation du virus est bien plus
importante que dans d'autres et donc les
mesures sont plus importantes et ce qui
justifie pour d'autres de ne pas encore
être à ceux à ce stade de contraintes
tout simplement
donc paris n'en fait pas partie a priori
puisque les transports en commun ont
desserré en tout cas les les mesures
belle et les autres villes n'ont pas non
plus eu ce loupé les transports en
commun d'un autre côté il faut bien
avoir conscience que le confinement
c'est quand même l'arrêt de toute
activité économique et sociale et il
serait sans doute pas souhaitable de
recommencer cet exercice donc il faut je
crois à faire appel à la responsabilité
des gens les gestes barrières sont
simples ce sont évidemment des
contraintes mais c'est à ce prix là
qu'on évitera 1re confinement qui serait
un désastre économique bien évidemment
est ce que je vais vous poser une
question en tant qu infectiologues est
ce que pour vous ce n'est pas trop tard
on voit que le gouvernement priorise
vous l'avez dit l'économie on a
l'impression que ils laissent faire en
tout cas dans les populations qui ne
sont pas à risque on
on va vers l'immunité collective sans
s'en dire oh non pas du tout pas du tout
les populations dites à moindre risque
ne se soumettent pas pour beaucoup aux
contraintes
donc ça c'est pas quelque chose qui est
organisée qui est voulu
c'est vécu comme ça et c'est appliqué
comme ça mais l'ensemble de la
population devrait impliquer les mesures
barrières
c'est un problème de responsabilité
envers les autres c'est à dire quand
vous êtes contagieux même si vous n'avez
pas une maladie grave vous pouvez la
transmettre à quelqu'un qui est à haut
risque et éventuellement provoquer des
décès on est dans ce registre là oui
mais alors le gouvernement justement
limite les restrictions on l'a vu la
période de quatorze haine qui est ramené
à sept jours des classes qui fermait
beaucoup et qui finalement revoit aussi
leur politique
on a l'impression que finalement la
population jeunes se dit on l'a vu dans
le reportage d'ailleurs sur sur les
journées du patrimoine les gens n'ont
pas l'air si inquiet que ça mais les
gens sont paniqués parce qu'ils ne
voient pas les morts que nous nous
voyons dans les hôpitaux ils ne voient
pas les réanimations il ya il ya une
distance entre la perception
effectivement de tout venant
et puis ce qui se passe réellement dans
les hôpitaux et tant qu'on ne voit pas
on se rend pas compte maintenant la
diminution de la 14è n'a une à une
semaine ça tient simplement compte des
nouvelles données épidémiologiques et de
données scientifiques que l'on a
maintenant tout simplement de même que
les mesures dans les écoles où on est
maintenant à peu près certain que la
transmission à l'intérieur des écoles et
des enfants vers les adultes est
relativement faible alors il ya aussi
cette politique des tests avec les
nouveaux tests salivaires qui ont été
validés est-ce que ça va améliorer les
choses
parce que pour l'instant
le délai est extrêmement long or le
délai est extrêmement long effectivement
parce que à peu près tout le monde a
accès à un test ou voudraient avoir
accès à un test que l'on soit une
personne contact où que l'on soit
vraiment à porteur de symptômes
il est vrai que les tests les tests
salivaires vont améliorer la rapidité du
résultat mais encore une fois ces tests
salivaires ne sont valables et ne sont
valides et que pour les personnes qui
ont des symptômes
tout simplement parce que là la quantité
de virus que l'on que l'on retrouve les
plus importantes et donc un pacte la
qualité du la qualité du test donc pour
les personnes malades
le ca va effectivement amélioré les
choses pour les personnes qui n'ont
aucun symptôme
c'est vrai qu'on va rester dans une dans
un encombrement
si je peux parler ainsi l'encombrement
actuelle inutile
un mot sur le plan blanc qui a été
déclenché dans certains hôpitaux
c'est la prochaine étape en tout cas
c'est là où le curseur se place pour
contrôler cette épidémie absolument mais
quand le plan blanc a été déclenché
comme dans mon hôpital par exemple quand
le plan blanc et des tanches et c'est
trop tard c'est avant qu'il aurait fallu
faire quelque chose je parle pas de la
politique des hôpitaux nous ont réagi
aux malades qu'on nous envoie mais c'est
avant que la prévention aurait dû être
importantes et là encore c'est un appel
à la responsabilité de la population
dans son ensemble
il est vrai que porter un masque ou se
tenir à distance des autres c'est
contraignant ça n'est pas forcément
drôle on a envie de faire autre chose
mais c'est le prix à payer pour éviter
des drames en aval oui donc vous vous
dites responsabilités tout en continuant
vivre normalement si je puis dire mais
en gardant ses distances hier le plus
louis le plus normalement possible
compte tenu de la contractent
merci beaucoup jean-paul vital d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce soir sur rtl
france